oh
[Laughter]
funny about the legal profession but
these so-called comic artists think that
they can besmirch My Chosen profession
well I'm not going to stand for it I'm
going to react to the best and worst
legal comics
[Music]
must be nice working in a big fancy
office must be nice to breathe the fresh
air experience direct sunlight to have a
job with clear instructions oh no
oh boy I mean yeah I mean especially
starting out you're a young associate at
a big Law Firm I always had a window in
my office a lot of my friends were on
the inside of an office building with no
direct sunlight for now why don't you go
ahead and get yourself a flashlight and
a can of pesticide and
excuse me
excuse me and believe it or not it's not
the the part about being outdoors that's
the worst part of being stuck inside
it's the the lack of clear instructions
you have no idea what you're supposed to
be doing for like
eight years and you're just learning on
the job so yeah I I feel this and yeah I
wish that there was a better way to give
instructions to Young Associates
my client cannot possibly be guilty of
baby murder Justice is a fallacious
platonic ideal we receive via
Christianity's Embrace of Greek thought
in the Middle Ages there's a reason no
one hires philosophy majors
I'll have to tell that to philosophy
tube and wisecrack oh man
yeah sometimes you can win an argument
and still lose the argument and if you
make these kind of of arguments You're
Gonna Lose also we just saw this in the
first episode of She-Hulk where someone
was making this like softest argument
what's the definition of knowing and
yeah my client killed all these people
but it was a business deal like
even if that was legally persuasive it's
not rhetorically persuasive and you're
You're Gonna Lose Your Case
Birds sleeping
sorry I'm late there were some problems
with a witness and I had to file I'm not
a lawyer am I I don't think so thank God
I was totally unprepared
oh no
oh that really hits home I I have to say
the the most stressful part about being
a practicing trial lawyer is not losing
a case or going up against some big wig
at another Law Firm it's really being
unprepared and specifically uh missing
some jurisdictional deadline you you
wake up in a cold sweat hoping that the
court isn't going to throw out your case
like for example you know if you have a
hearing in Orange County and you're in
Santa Monica and you set your alarm for
PM instead of am and then you wake up at
nine o'clock and the hearings at 9 30
and you know then you have to pray that
some of your colleagues are in Orange
County luckily one of your partners in
in Santa Ana so you give them a call and
plead with them to show up in court so
that your case doesn't get thrown out
yeah I mean that's never happened to me
but I can imagine how that might happen
to somebody else and how that would be a
very stressful situation if you're not
prepared or you you know don't show up
to court so yeah this is poor bird
luckily he's not a lawyer and doesn't
have any of those responsibilities
professional life no we will not agree
to the sneaky provision you tried to
bury in section 15 D of the agreement
personal life do I agree to the 35
35 page terms and conditions to play
Animal Crossing fast girl except give me
the game
now there are some issues with contracts
of adhesion but for the most part these
contracts tend to be enforceable and
yeah just you know give me the uh give
me the Animal Crossing and one of the
best episodes of South Park really one
of the best episodes of Comedy ever is
where they talk about someone who
oh did not read all the terms and
conditions before they signed it and I
won't spoil what happens in that episode
but it's absolutely brilliant definitely
worth watching and a great satire of you
know the whole legal industry 83 pounds
god let's get the blood work probably
you can't do that you agreed we could
take all the blood we needed what are
you talking about when you downloaded
the last iTunes update a window a new
screen popped up and asked you if you
agreed to our terms and conditions you
clicked agree all right let's get into
the water tank
a cat killer is the face of a cat killer
cat Chaser maybe but hey who is it
man I Missed The Far Side so good I
think there's a problem with this jury
it's a dog representing another dog in a
jury full of cats the judge is a
presiding cat everyone in the gallery is
a cat this is completely unfair I will
not stand for this Injustice
I object council is trying to confuse
the jury with the intent of the law
completely ignoring the loopholescent
technicalities
so sometimes that works sometimes it
doesn't sometimes the law is written in
such a way that it's supposed to have
loopholes and technicalities but also I
have to take issue with this particular
comic you're not going to be arguing the
law in front of the jury this is
something that you'd only argue to the
judge the jury doesn't get to decide the
law the law is given to them that's what
jury instructions are for which is why
people hate lawyers and no TV shows are
accurate because it's uh day to day
super boring super boring
I'll close this deal in a three-minute
montage spend quality time with my kids
and still have time for a steamy side
romance how does anyone have time to do
anything
a TV lawyer definitely seems like it's a
better job also on TV they're never
writing any kinds of briefs they're
never doing legal research they're just
chord with no preparation whatsoever
having done none of the briefing and
they expect to win their case I mean
She-Hulk that we saw just a few weeks
ago it was so bad at this legal
inaccuracies make Devin mad and in real
life you don't have time for everything
it's just
I thought I was guilty until my lawyer
straightened me out on that
so all right funny but
there are a number of clients who will
come to you thinking that they might
have done something wrong or not being
sure one of my my partners said that any
lawyer can tell a client not to do
something but a great lawyer will tell
them that they can because it's it's
just so easy to say no you it's legally
irresponsible but to really put your
reputation on the line and say that yes
you can do something that's what lawyers
really get paid for and that's that's
top tier lawyering sweet no it has to be
true you have to have a legal basis to
say that you can do something when
someone is worried about it but that's
that's the real trick as a lawyer
Law Firm partner 3am Law Firm associate
3am did I accidentally insert an extra
comma in section 8.13 K of the stock
purchase agreement oh my God like
you get so in depth in these contracts
and yeah you'll have nightmares about a
missing comma one tiny missing word a
wrong indentation it'll absolutely give
you nightmares this this comic
definitely seems to know the legal
practice pretty well this lawyer has
been injured does anyone speak lilies
I don't get it
lawyers injured why would they speak a
different language
I I think that one could be better
don't worry you won't hurt my feelings
I'm a lawyer I resemble that remark
lawyers have feelings allegedly you can
you know make us hurt theoretically it's
possible allegedly speaking no that
being said uh maybe we don't exactly
wear our hearts on our sleeves because
we're constantly fighting people all day
including sometimes our clients so you
know all right maybe maybe there is some
truth to that uh fine I'll get up and
feed you no need to get the lawyers
involved
damn cats
the cats are clearly the most litigious
of all the animals in the animal kingdom
just uh just jerks
[Music]
no I said paralegals
all right let's go Legal Eagles
could you draft these terms into a
contract I trust your lawyerly expertise
on this oh absolutely you're in great
hands with me how to draft a contract a
few minutes later
oh no okay I don't know if I should
admit this but I'm teaching class at the
Georgetown law school I've been teaching
it for a couple years now and I was
talking to the class what's the first
thing that you would do when you would
research this particular topic that we
were talking about and they answered oh
I would go on Westlaw and do case law
research I go on LexisNexis and I'd find
the statutory Authority uh you know et
cetera et cetera and I told them really
the first thing that you should do
there's no shame in it just Google it
totally legitimate sometimes there's
good stuff out there it costs the client
nothing whereas a lot of these databases
are really expensive to run searches and
it's you can't trust it you have to
check it but search Google first why not
as with any lawsuit you'll go through
seven stages anger denial bargaining
Tantrums hostages acceptance bankruptcy
the number of clients who have come to
me and said I'm going to fight this all
the way to the Supreme Court only to
turn around and not even file a suit
when I say that okay great so it's going
to cost you you know thousands of
dollars an hour it's going to take
thousands of hours to take this case to
a verdict let alone to appeal and Beyond
um yeah this is very accurate that many
cases and in bankruptcy because people
have no idea how much it costs they're
angry they think it's worth fighting uh
until they see the price tag and then
they are absolutely done and let bygones
be bygones
perhaps you'd like to rephrase your last
answer
yeah that's a terrible Witness terrible
witness right there
actually I'm a litigator that's just a
solid pun I'll allow it fantastic
big law fail sodium 21 where's your
markup of the merger documents you said
you'd have it by the end of the day
right I meant like 11 59 PM uh that's
just that's so true and and the funny
thing is what happens is you send an
email at 11 59 PM saying oh I'm almost
done and really there's no point in me
sending it at midnight so I'll send it
to you by 7 00 a.m the next day so you
get to work through the night on that
thing that is so accurate it's so
accurate
oh no what is it the human filter isn't
working what are you gonna tell the
judge don't worry I got this
a lot of cats
oh that was so good what a great moment
for all of us in the pandemic to just
sit there and laugh at the poor guy with
a cat filter on his uh Zoom I'm here
live it's not I'm not a cat
and the human filter for cats that's
that's very crafty I I like it but it
was it was a cat the whole time you've
got to be kidding me
bad news is you're to be executed at
dawn good news is your executioner isn't
a morning person
oh that's dark that is quite dark
let's review each other's briefs and
make our oral arguments a lawyer is
flirting
I mean if you get it you get it
I think these two are in foursome
susponte in flagrante delicto that is
they're going to moot each other all
night
I'm so uncomfortable right now
your work is riddled with typos and
other unmentionables I thought you said
I could send a draft when I said send a
draft I mean send the final document I
can hang in the Sistine Chapel so many
people make this mistake and uh yeah
when when a partner says send a draft
what they mean is send an absolute
perfect document and then they'll just
Redline the hell out of it anyway but
yeah draft does not mean draft
so many people make this mistake oh and
and that gives rise to the email where
you just reply back and say
please fix which means this whole
document is horrible you've got to
change everything about it when you see
please fix that's like the worst thing
that you can possibly get as a
responsive email
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
I only have a few minutes to grab a
quick lunch near the office who are all
these people enjoying themselves
leisurely on a weekday don't they have
jobs
yeah yeah
uh especially when you're practicing in
LA and I swear like 90 of the people you
know like don't have regular jobs here
in DC at least most people have jobs and
they're on a regular schedule but man
you just walk outside in L.A and
everyone is I don't know surfing and
riding a skateboard and having a good
time uh it's just jerks occupation
Surfer
[Music]
good job Surfer
not really
your honor my client would like to plead
this sit yeah you can do that but it
looks like you're pretty guilty like you
sliced a Jedi in half
foreign
[Music]
world if you plead the Sith you probably
can't uh take that uh as
self-incrimination against your your
defendant so I bet in a galaxy far far
away this is non-prejudicial completing
the Sith
[Music]
now if these comic lawyers were real
lawyers they'd probably need to look for
a new job and they could really benefit
from today's sponsor 80 000 hours
they're a non-profit that helps people
find careers that aim at solving the
world's most pressing problems if you
care about what the evidence actually
says about having a fulfilling and
impactful career and want real advice
that goes beyond the empty cliches like
Follow Your Passion then 80 000 hours
can help many sources simply give cookie
cutter advice and only recommend a few
well-known career paths that people
often think have high social impact like
being a doctor or a teacher or a charity
worker boo now no those are great but
those aren't your only options and
they're probably aren't your best
options either trust me no career
aptitude test told me to be a YouTube
lawyer and most importantly relevant
career advice can be really hard to find
if you care a lot about making a big
positive difference in the world now 80
000 hours is a nonprofit that aims to
help you find a career that is both
fulfilling and makes a big positive
difference they've done over 10 years of
research alongside academics at Oxford
University and to how to find a
fulfilling career that does a lot of
good and it turns out that the best way
to make a positive difference might be
pretty different from what you think
they avoid platitudes and unsupported
generalizations in fact all the
recommendations are based on careful
research in consultation with experts in
relevant fields and when they aren't
sure of something they say so plus
everything they provide is free forever
because they're a non-profit their only
aim is to help solve Global Problems by
helping people find the most impactful
careers they can so this one is a
no-brainer if you're thinking about your
career if you'd like a free copy of 80
000 hours in-depth career guide that
helps you learn about what makes for a
high impact career get new ideas for
impactful paths and make a new plan
based on what you've learned then just
click on the link that's in the
description or on screen right now
you'll also get access to their free
newsletter with updates on the research
and high impact job opportunities again
all you have to do is click on the link
that's on screen right now or down in
the description to start planning a
career that is Meaningful fulfilling and
helps solve one of the world's most
pressing problems and after that click
on this link over here for more legal
eagle or I'll see you in court